Probably ok when we go. One. Great concern i have twenty years after the name an experiment started. Is that the ideas.
And effects of the. The nimbin inverted commas. Workforce are certainly the best we have i think.
We need something got lost. It's twit it's not twenty years since the newman experiment began.
And i feel more than ever that the idea is an ethics of that era. Were exceptionally fine.
And we don't have to apologize for these things. But what concerns me enormously is that often the.
Energy levels don't match the ideas. And as opposed to this we have normal society where.
Often there's tremendous energy. But it's usually destructive energy.
And somehow we have to marry the ideas in aspirations and and. Wonderful philosophies. Of the new age.
We think energy and ability and strength of the the old age of what you like to call it.
I don't know how we do that because at the moment the energies and strengths of conventional society.
Are destroying the planet. And we have to turn it around somehow.
But sometimes when you see that lack of motivation amongst. Local grains.
And the idea that somehow a lot just work out by itself. I despair. But in the long term i think.
Somehow those ideas will come through and we will manage to meet them. We see activity levels as well.
We have to be in it for the long haul we don't have a choice. We all have to work as well as we can.
And the main way to do that at the moment is to keep. Positivity levels up. And i think this is where the.
The american comic. Friend previous got an enormous amount to teach us.
Because she is seems to have dedicated her life. Lightly to recognising the despair levels.
In not only greens but a lot of the other people. On the planet. And she makes.
Quite obvious the fact that you're not going to be effective in anything you fought for unless you stay positive
and often that means laughing. So her mission. Is in fact. To make people laugh.
About subjects that i guess you would call. Gallows humor there really terrible prospect death of. Planet nuclear war.
Pollution on the grand scale but she can make us laugh about it and. In that way empower us completely.
And so some of the dimensions that she's used in her talks i just find. Tremendously powerful for me. One of them is.
This is the mantra that you say after you've been pretty depressed about a particular issue. And it goes.
Oh what a disappointment and. Another. Another mantra of hers. Or slogan is. The people you know i did.
Well sometimes win and sometimes lows.
And
when she says this in a big auditorium it brings the house down because we've all been there we've all ford issues
and lost them and feel that was the end of the world.
But she's teaching us to pick ourselves up and keep going it's ok to lose. That might be the end of the world.
But it's not the end of you for the moment. Yes i do think there is quite a significant burnout level.
Amongst a lot of the old aquarians.
But against that we have an extremely hopeful sign of a whole new breed of people have in fact made an industry out of.
Keeping people positive. And these people are extremely skilled and. Specialized in the book.
And these people are going to be the ones that really matter in the end. Because they can get us going again.
And i think it's fair enough to take a lot of knock backs the planet is in bad shape. So it's.
It's ok to be depressed about it.
We just have to make sure we have a few little skills to get us back on track so we can keep fighting
and feel that there is some reason to keep going because basically we don't have a choice do we can't back out. We're.
In here we're stuck. And the only thing is to keep going and the only way to keep going is to stay positive.
So it's a bit of a circle but. If you look at the right way you can feel it's all worthwhile.
When you look at the beauty of the place how can you not fight for it.
I always wonder why do people feel that it's hopeless. It's obvious that you have to keep going. Thank you. No to.
Young hugh nicholson.
I came to the area to throw me a creek in one hundred seventy four i was the teacher in norman and.
Gradually became more and more aware of problems of pollution and environmental degradation or it was tough and.
Although i was getting through to.
Kids with my teaching i just filled in what i really wanted to do was to try and live.
A simpler lifestyle and see what was possible rather than just trying to tell people about where you could do it.
And so. With and then i set off looking for land and after of years searching we found a place here.
And tried to actually dropped out i guess you'd say. Supposedly living a subsistence lifestyle and very simply.
But in fact. It's extraordinary good to food to do anything but not only difficult but.
Living a subsistence life at the start was incredibly boring.
Because you've got to work you've got an every day and you've got to make sure that the birds don't pinch your fruit
and and. Then there are some things that you can't produce readily like bryce or weight or whatever.
And you do need some money to buy so you end up getting caught up in that cycle on that system anyway.
But we still have a lot of those philosophies are producing what i'm talking we can. From our own place and.
Still living. A simpler lifestyle and. Nice people but. We not been to on pure self-sufficiency anymore.
It was an end at the time we came it was what we intended to do.
But within a couple weeks of arriving at the running a creek. We heard of.
Forest commission plans to log around your creek and when we followed up.
That inquiry we found out that the plans were. To log. All the millivolt timber.
And then to clear feller east and burn it and plant. With g.v. Plant eucalypts.
And only two species because they're the only trees that will grow faster than lantana and. So our intention.
And what they were doing in the rest of the local state forests at that time was no clearing about five hundred acres a
year and. Replanting it. Do you call it a flood again and blacked out and. Since we look out on to this.
To ronnie creek on the walls of rainforest and so on here. The concept of having that converted from rainforest to.
Eucalypt plantation. Full of lantana. Was just absolutely beyond comprehension so that's why we started fighting.
Complaining. Well i've just happened to be here one day and to hear a vehicle up in the forest and.
We were at the end of of a one way road as far as i was aware that there was no road beyond us.
And when i walk through the forest.
To explore and try
and track down the sound i found that there was an old forest road coming down the side of the hill and. There was a.
Forestry road gang and working there cleaning up the water tables and.
I asked whether they had any intentions of using that road for access to to ronnie creek
and were they playing to logon. In their innocence the. The fellows on the working said yes.
And i think i've learned a lot since then i don't tend to be so open with their answers anymore.
And so having got a yes from them that they would be in sometime we immediately contacted the office in mumbai which is
a local forestry office and asked. What were the intentions. And again.
Because they hadn't confronted a situation like this before with people opposing what i was doing.
They were open with their answers and said yes they're intended to clear philip byrne and converted you.
And so it went on from there. You. Was about five years.
Of ongoing letters to politicians trying to develop a public awareness so we were conducting walks up into the forest
with anybody you want to go and. Part of the problem with that was that. Some of the forest.
Had been logged in the past and so it was unlocked but it was about a two hour walk.
Because the old logging road was very lantana no sore start and it made slow walking so about time you got somebody.
Two hours into the forest they were ready to turn around or come out again because they are mostly city people
and their impression was at all being logged.
And they didn't actually get to see this other major portion of it we hadn't been logged in the past
and was absolutely spectacular. And so we were. We were up against that as a problem. Quite often.
That people didn't have the stamina to actually see understood forest and.
Didn't have the knowledge to appreciate the effects that loading it had on the other force and.
The absolute highlight of the blockade for me was the. Organization of the camp.
I was just so impressed by the ability of. What a so-called derogatorily called he piece. To coordinate.
So will the camp. Within the first by the. The first. The end of the first day.
Or second day we had water on to the camp. And from then on for the. Four weeks or whatever it was of the camp.
There was hot. Running water for showers. At any time day or night. There were incredible meals cooked.
We had donations of food from more shopkeepers would donate stuff and and.
People would go out and buy supplies and bring them in donate them to the camp and there were.
There was one group of people who just decided to be the cooks. And they put on three course meals.
Every day it was just brilliant. They were better in fact than a lot better than we were eating.
Back at our house because we were so involved in. Phone calls and media stuff.
That there was often not time to prepare me it was it was really scratch me it was out there there were did people
dedicated to just getting the meal and then there were fire wood gatherers and. And so on and.
So that was in the camp itself. And back here at the house. We had people with. Media skills.
We had one guy who every day would pull a fine apart and connect these wires into a scene these press releases off.
Directly through the phone. And there was a. Duplicating machine a p.r.
Corner where from but it appeared and it was in the galleries just. And every night. It was. Duplicating off.
Press release and so on for handouts to the media
when they turned up the next day so it was just incredibly well organized and it all just. Time together.
And i found that fascinating and interesting me after four weeks of occupy. Ation of a campsite.
There was no rubbish there. The only sign that people had been there was the grass was a bit flattened.
And a couple of people had levelled sloping down to put a team.
That was in there was all the rubbish had been buried and all that so stuff and yet.
Within a week of the camp being dismantled. There were opposing groups who were coming out having rallies.
In the area trying to promote their angle. And invariably we had to spend a day after each one of these.
Cleaning up the rubbish and they gathered afterwards it was really dramatic contrast in comparison. Well.
It wasn't a pua victory i guess it was a victory in that. The logging was stopped.
And it's interesting to talk about the politics of the actual stopping of the logging because everyone stage the.
Loggers were intent on feeling as many trees as possible and so they were just coming in
and dropping trees as fast they could almost on the run they'd fill a tree.
And some of these trees were radio carbon dated at in excess of a thousand years
and that all really impressive trees and. The figures that we got were that there were about six hundred trees.
That was all in toronto to create it was a very minor issue really and.
They found out that if they logged as fast as they could.
Then they could get twenty trees a day on the ground and often that meant.
Falling trees across each other which in some cases split the trunk so it was incredibly wasteful.
But only just really going forward.
And you buy one friday afternoon that deadspin today are doing is just filling trees as fast as possible.
And then they knocked off and went home for the weekend and. Over the weekend. Somebody. And we still don't know who.
Somebody went up and actually cut up. The fallen trees into. To me the links. They just saw through them.
With a chainsaw and. There was a lot of adverse. Media from that and the.
Storming lobby obviously picked up on it as being the most horrendous lady vandeleur stick thing to have done.
But what it meant was that when they came back next week. They only filled. Three trees a day.
Because the trees were so big that i can only fit part of a tree. On a logging jinger.
And i could only take nine trucks out a day and.
It slowed the whole operation down they worked on for another week and they cut another twenty trees.
But if they hadn't been stymied by the feeling and by the cutting up of the fallen logs.
They would have had the job half done in that way. So it was interesting how how that. Action which.
Got a lot of bad press was in fact what save the forest and now of course everybody says. It around to create.
What a benchmark decision that was the forerunner of. Of this world heritage rainforest which we are also proud of but.
It comes from what was seen as being. And yes. Rare as a politician was on the side but.
He we had a very divided cabinet.
And so it was a fine balancing act
and he got caught up in in trying to spin the thing out long enough to get enough people in cabinet to to come on side.
And so on in the way that the logging was stopped yes we won. But. We then had an inquiry and.
I would never ever recommend anybody again. Asking for an inquiry.
As being the way out of an issue because we got involved in an exhausting.
Inquiry that went on for thirty two years i think and.
The forestry people had all their experts in the sawmill is had their paid it. Birds and.
We were expected to be there to put our case.
If we weren't there when we were unable to refute the stuff that they said. But obviously.
All of it came out of our pockets and. That went against us too because the judge said. We were in there.
Not for financial gain. But because we were emotionally involved. And if we were inviting me involved.
Then obviously our evidence was suspect. Whereas these guys working for forestry commission.
Who are being paid to do their job and if they didn't say the right things would lose their job. That was ok.
Obviously everything i said was perfectly true and correct. It was a very difficult inquiry.
It was hard during the inquiry to stay. Enthusiastic. Tell you a classic.
One of our people was giving evidence on the wildlife use of the forest and the need for.
Old growth trees with olive branches.
And he'd gone into quite a long explanation of the types of animals the possums and the gliders and the elves
and all the stuff that uses.
Hollow branches in the fact that a number of these are rare and endangered animals
and they are current around you creek. And after page of evidence. On this the judge finally turned to him and said.
I can see the relevance of this information. The lawyers don't take the hollow branches they lift. In the forest.
What's the problem. So the judge could not see that hollow branches one hundred feet in the ground.
Used by animals that use the canopy of the forest. He believes that the same branches lying on the forest floor.
Would be just as useful. To the owls and possums. So he's view was that.
Just taking up the stems and leaving the branches. Was quite ok so he's. Understanding of.
Ecological points was nonexistent. He was horrified and for us he couldn't stand it.
And one stage we took all the rest of the enquiry down to. A particular.
Pool in the creek where the locals had used it for picnics for fifty years they have been visiting this place.
And he couldn't get there because he was so old and decrepit that he couldn't get off the track. And so we.
When we got back up to the cows and he was asking what we had seen.
And we told him of the people reporting back to him told him what they had seen and his response that was.
Were there any picnic tables chairs barbecues.
The answer was no so he displayed all the evidence that anybody might have used that place for picking it was
ridiculous to assume that people would use it. There weren't barbecues and picnic tables in.
It was a lie to suggest that people use that place. He couldn't comprehend people going to the forest for enjoyment.
And being prepared to walk. It was an uphill battle was hooey.
I think that unfortunately i think that there are still a lot of people who are city based.
Who would still see feel the same way. And that is the battle now for the green movement.
Is to get through to the people who don't relate to the natural environment that.
No matter what they think the natural environment relates to them. And that they're tied up with it.
And that they can't escape it. And i think for people who live all a life in the city.
It is possible to believe that the problems that are talked about don't exist.
And if in fact you live in a how to get in a car park in a covered car park and go to work in an office. Come home.
You don't need to know what the moon is doing you don't need to know when it's clouding raining.
Unless there's a bit of an inconvenience of the weekend so you don't need to relate to the environment. And that.
That is the problem. You're getting kids who are growing up in this you know don't see trees who don't run on grass.
So it's people like that who who find it really hard to relate to the environment. And to see that.
Problems of pollution. Will eventually have an effect on them. The rubbish that they produce.
Has to go into a landfill somewhere and. Landfill sites are running out.
What do we do with the rubbish do we in fact do what they do in america and take out the seed and barge
and just are going to bottom and dump it.
There's a limit to how many times you can do that you're working on table a day it's the sixth of december
and you know. And we're speaking with spain. Hayes. It's p i n n portugal. Ok. And you sell and say.
Yes but my name is david spain. I made forty five now. I came to town double falls in early not in seventy five.
At that time i'd been living alone in the countryside. North of bathurst.
And working in the attorney general's department as a liaison officer. Trying to get a fix on.
What was wrong with the world and how to set it right. Why there were such phenomena.
And as especially the war in vietnam for which i amongst many other of my then ballot of the in the increasing
pollution which was becoming obvious. Twenty years ago or so of inner cities. Rich poor gap. Unemployment.
That's part of the post war by bieber and generation which. Always grew up with pace and plenty.
The vietnam war was an enormous culture shock. I think to. All of my generation. That such a horrific.
Occurrence could. Embroil us personally.
Think of scripted was an affront to the spirit and conscience to fight a war we saw as little intellectual life.
After the war of course with them came to power. That was your four year. Suddenly the possibility of really building.
Examples of utopian. Lifestyle in a strange. And evidencing allow impact and way of life.
Which made big centralized government unnecessary. Allowed people to only work a day or two awake for income.
And the rest of the time. Either. For some. Subsistence farming or building their own homes.
Exploring the finer things of life music. Grading meditation. This whole.
Utopian view stuff because i'm possible of implementation or so it's aimed.
Then the queries festival was held in may of not in seventy three. It was a coming together of this flower power. Love.
Idealism a sense of empathy between people which was the product of the post-war generation. Coming up against the.
Agnus of viet nam conflict. And i'm sure. Psychedelic drugs had a lot to do with it.
It's quite a unique generation looking back. And. Out of the aquarius festival. Came. The project.
Of buying a property and. Setting up a permanent. Sustainable community. Into elling.
Those ideals which we held during the previous decade.
Shares were sold for a mere two hundred dollars in total for gradually this was sold to some people who bought a share
in an idea. Others who came to settle here. And within two or three years this entire property.
Hundred four thousand dollars. Had been subscribed to and paid off. The valleys.
Spearing in from the south to the nightcap range with spare lines running down into the clear valley.
And timber along the ridges. The initial settlers. Bearing and amber between forty and seventy or so.
Mostly lived together in the old farmhouse the center of the property.
Which was painted white and was ironically called the white house. At the north end.
Was another worker's cottage where a group of fifteen or twenty settled themselves. So initially the.
Political motivation would have been close to communist utopia where the idea was everyone living and working together.
In some wholly happy organism. But within a year or so there are a lot of tensions developing in the workers hired.
Obliges. The people who wear particular to drugs who would want to do the smoking.
Magic mushrooms and so on all the time. Vegetarians don't like the late eighty's. One reason or another the initial.
Communist utopia. Fell apart and. Groups of people who were basically like minded. Went off and pioneered hamlet.
Settlements on the spur lines coming down in the valleys. Very quickly they were fifteen twenty maybe thirty.
Of these little hamlets. Groups of three five six households.
In the hamlets the settlers are semi autonomous from the cooperative.
And belong to the cooperative there was no survey title. Given to any individual shareholder.
People started building homes and it quickly became realised that some sort of control was necessary.
One big guy friend was brought high up on a ridge. Its roof obvious up and down the entire length of the valley.
And rules were quickly passed that. People who wanted to build houses had to get. Co-operative approval.
First a flag had to be rise to the height of the intended roof
and i'd just given in a month later approval could be sought. And then the local council got in on the act.
And required building plans. So the co-operative made it a condition of granting the approval. That.
Council approval plans be filed with the secretary at the same time. So people. Built their own homes.
Norma's for royalty of homes. Often just small timber. Cabins with a single room and of a rare. Sometimes homes which.
Approximate in size and normal australian suburban home. Sometimes quite rear. Unusual.
Buildings such as a star own house or a fair or cement. Diam. People pretty well left a charger alone.
Does her industrious work to building their homes. Planting orchards.
Others quickly brought a bit of shelter and perhaps did nothing after death
or perhaps focus their energies on some aspect of music or. Environmental activism. The cooperative mates.
At an annual general meeting once a year and elect a board. Under the rules of the cooperative.
The board has ultimate power to make decisions for and binding upon the entire community or shareholders.
For a long time. The. Elected board was more or less nominal.
It didn't exercise any independent power because this invited. Accusations of being. Some sort of fascist totalitarian.
The community instead. Net every month. At what was called a trouble meeting. And it was this.
Amorphous meeting of ever happened to turn up once a month which tended to make decisions and.
From time to time implement them. Alive. My observation would be that. And still use that.
Nice paper three lived to act as policeman.
A lot of decisions are being made over and over again reinventing the wheel over the years.
Not enforced or implemented. But perhaps gradually there's building up a consciousness of what will be disciplined and.
What will be tolerated. It's very liberal liberal liberal. Little liberal communities growing out of it.
Seen enormous tolerance for differences.
Folk tend to live each other alone unless they absolutely transgress the guidelines. It's always sad and very that.
They spend so little endeavor. As regards growing orchards and vegetable gardens.
These are still a lot of waves on the hillsides. There's still a lot of dependence on welfare.
When one would have hoped. Five could be undone.